said we couldn't compete with the
richest school for the nation the
Washington boat has taken the lead
Washington has done it I got 9 seconds
under the course record Olympic year
this year Olympic year I didn't realize
that bunch of kids load like no one else
that's ever come through here everybody
else tires they just get stronger we
have a both that I believe could qualify
for an Olympic
spot George this movie really for me
works on two different levels I think
it's kind of a yes it's kind of a
Timeless yeah lesson on teamwork and you
know kind of working it all out as a
group it's also in a great tradition of
kind of beautiful throwback period
Sports films like a seab biscuit or a
Field of Dreams even how did you want to
balance those two different elements
well I don't know we all kind of like
sports films you know um hooers is a big
one um the natural films like that we
had an advantage because it's a true
story like all the things that you see
in here um happened so we didn't have to
cheat them you know they the kid really
got sick the coach the other coach gave
them the money they missed the start um
you know all of those things happen so
if it helps a little bit it makes it
easier so that you know you don't get
sort of stuck trying to make the story
better I mean Grant obviously the The
Source material the book by Daniel James
Brown people just rever this book what
was it about it that you wanted to kind
of make sure obviously you can't get
every aspect of the book into a two
two-hour film but what was most
important to you that it came through
the book is just a it's a beautiful book
about the the you know the the the human
spirit and um our job was really to not
mess it up you know yeah was to try to
um we we stuck to the story very closely
the hardest part really was just kind of
condensing it Joel Orson is not the
typically inspiration coach right he's
he's uh he's spare with his words why do
you think he was effective and what did
you most enjoy about playing it I've
always sort of been fascinated by
coaches that that appear to derive zero
Joy from their
job um but it's always been a clue that
they care more than everybody else you
know I I think there was something great
about the script laying that out that he
was a little bit more removed almost
like a like a a hard to reach dad his
vision in the beginning is really just
about the mechanics of putting eight
different bodies in a boat and working
it all out in a kind of a mathematical
way and his speeches reflect that and
then moving towards you know this this
place of actually understanding each
each of the boys more individually and
seeing their personalities and and and
therefore cracking open a little bit of
warmth you know and love Callum from
your point of view with in the casting
process and talking to George and Grant
was it more them convincing you that
they could make you into someone who
could row convincingly or was it you
convincing them that you were like in
good enough shape to take on a role like
this yeahum this a long we don't have
time for this answer you know I
basically sent in a tape it was a pretty
straightforward process and I go on a
Skype with uh George and Grant and um
you know the truth is that George and
Grant they set our to succeed you know
it was the closest experience I'll ever
have to being part of a professional
sports team we had a a trainer that won
uh gold at Atlanta for rowing and uh we
went down to Radley there um facilities
a second to
n uh you know it was a it was a
wonderful time and a special special
experience I don't think I'll ever have
anything like that on a film again Tanya
I want to give you so much credit
because your editing on this is
phenomenal it's unbelievable how did did
you get to a point together that it felt
like it was enough exciting without
going overboard we did a rough assembly
we made sure we hit the right plot
points and then we just evolved it from
there and and we would try things and
George would watch it and he'd just
email me we were on different time zones
at the time when we finished cutting the
Olympics and he was just like I like it
just keep cutting just add more cuts and
and it just it it was different from the
other two races because it we did
escalate that and and go quicker quicker
quicker and and so I I think that and
then we built to those beautiful uh
homage to Lenny reall shots where you
know there's so many things in that race
that happen that you we were afraid we
would you know hit the height too early
so it was really important for us to
make sure that that the tension grew and
grew and grew until we hit that last set
of shots before the photo finish all of
the racing scenes were shot
chronologically so we as an audience see
you guys basically getting better and
getting stronger do you think it would
have been just as good if it hadn't been
shot that way or was that necessary no
because we wouldn't have been as good
and and and I meant that when I said
that these guys set us up to succeed
they they scheduled those races for the
last month last three weeks I think of
of the shoot so we were in Peak physical
condition and we were in the best moment
in our rowing and uh you know five
months feels like a long time but we
were all learning a new skill for the
first time which is hard enough rowing
is and excruciating skill to learn it
was so difficult um but we were also
learning to surrender our identities and
become one which was probably the
hardest part and you see that nine
actors are you kidding
exactly and uh you know you see that in
the film you know when when when Joe
falls out of that sink the boat suffers
and and and and that was true for for us
too and uh we set oursel the target of
the 46 Strokes per minute which the guys
do in in Berlin at the beginning and and
and boy it just felt like it was an
impossible thing to achieve and the
closer we got to the end the further
away it felt and then on the second last
day we were we were doing that race and
we were really in it and and and we hit
that 46 which you know we're making a
movie alongside learning how to roll and
trying to do this thing and uh there was
there was a it was just euphoric in the
boat for us to be able to have done that
and and together and and actually that's
the beautiful thing about rowing is that
it's team sport unlike any other and um
you really do have to sacrifice yourself
for the great good George I know there's
like a perfect storm joke here but I
also get the sense that you maybe
underestimated the challenges of
shooting on the water well yeah I mean I
didn't underestimate I did perfect storm
for nine
months I've been in the water but I
forgot I'm old man I forgot and I got
out there and we started you know doing
storyboards and on this and I'm
like yeah wait wait a minute wait a
minute and you know the just the things
of like that the boats themselves just
to just for the start you have eight
boats lined up and the wind is blowing
you can't they're all going like this we
had scuba divers underneath the thing
holding the boat like you know just to
try and just to get a start off it was a
nightmare but you know you you know
ignorance is bliss forgetting things is
it's really helpful at times you know
Joel from your point of view when all of
these young actors were like going
through the intense training how much
did you step in and show solidarity by
you know doing all the workouts with
them can I answer this yeah there wasn't
much solidarity the solidarity was
watching George and Joe and gr drink red
wine as we rode past busting a gut boys
in the bar boys in the bar that's that's
a sequel the uh with all seriousness
though I've you know been through that
process of training hard for a movie and
and you know and then I was like oh now
I'm the coach which means I'm getting a
bit older and um but then watch she
turning up to the to the river and
watching these guys all you know put in
the hard work and watching The Evolution
and and their whole demeanor skill set
shift and then galvanized as a team and
I I was I I knew that it was going to be
a great experience for them through the
pain and it was just a real pleasure to
watch them go through that experience
and not have to be them as well of
course I I was I was very envious of
them in in many ways and it was very
impressive Tanya when you think I mean
you you've have so many interesting
credits and so many different things
that you've done in your career when you
think back to this particularly some of
the racing sequences does this rank up
there as one of the more challenging
jobs that you've had I don't think it
was challenging in that the footage was
fantastic the performances were like I
had so much wonderful clay to work with
and obviously working with Granton
George is totally a pleasure pleasure
but you know it's something that I'd
never done before I'd cut action
sequences in the past but this was
special it was totally different and and
um it was extraordinarily gratifying
when we finally got to a place where
we're like yeah we got this and now that
we're hearing audiences clap and and
enjoyed the film it's it's it's just
feels even better it's fun to watch like
we were in Seattle we screen in Seattle
packed house you know a bunch of rowers
there and it's fun to watch the audience
row
they'll
which is really pretty you know so you
you you get a movie and a workout nice
yes that's good Grant are you I hope I'm
not about to put my foot in my mouth
here is so I hope you are Daniel James
Brown is with us still or oh yeah yeah
okay has he's he's the guy that wrote
the book has he seen it has he oh my God
yeah he's seen it he's seen it a bunch
he he loved it I mean look that's always
the scariest thing is to show to the
author CU if they don't like it then you
feel like you're in trouble um but we
screened it for him over at Warner
Brothers kind of a family and friend
screening and he he he was weeping yeah
it was great yeah that's always
dangerous too you know when the author
weeps you know Grant and Tanya and I
have you know because it's a beloved
book you know but we also did catch 22
the three of us so you know but but
hel's dead so you know how much can
you get from him um so it was you know
so we were very concerned about that cuz
if we got that wrong we were going to
get in trouble we showed it uh when we
were up in Seattle uh Joe rance's
daughter was there and uh some of
pocock's family was there and you know
family were it's a love letter this this
film yeah uh final thing George I know
over talking to you over the years I
remember you've said to me that it was a
goal of yours to get to a point which
you clearly have where you could direct
films without the studio saying well you
have to also be in it for us to aged out
of that but here you are in not in this
but also like here's sesi doing a little
bit part at the end of killers with the
flower moon like would you now consider
doing like a Hitchcock esque cameo in
your F walk that's all I'm allowed to do
anymore um yeah I know scorsese's
working his way backwards he wants to
act again um yeah I don't know yeah I
there was no nothing for me to play that
I wouldn't it wouldn't have been
distracting and uh we had such wonderful
actors it's a lot easier than you know
directing yourself so no I'm not going
to you know unless like Lifeboat with
Hitchcock where you put yourself in the
newspaper there you go something to
consider for next time I congratulate
you all it's a beautiful film it's so
exciting George Callum Joel Grant Tanya
well done thanks so much for sticking
around get some sleep have a great
night